james s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir spielen heute jump
league und wir haben wieder eine
zuschauer zum start die kommt von nach
wehr heißt marie sophie apfel thailand
sie sagt die eppo wieder stimmungs mit
dem normalen niveau wie anfangen und
jedes mal wenn du runter fällt das evo
vii um zwei in niedriger stellen
ich hab mir das auch mal ein paar
gedanken gemacht und zwar dachte ich mir
es am coolsten wenn wir auf quake pro
anfangen das auf dem höchsten niveau wie
das zu kennzeichnen und dann für jedes
abgeschlossene module nicht um zwei
runtergehen dann um 10 das ist die hrc
ich habe übrigens auch okay ich habe
übrigens auch immer eine kleine umfrage
zum thema jump league gestartet weil ich
gern wissen mag was ihr davon haltet das
jetzt der job bekommt da ist ein link
zur straw poll in der beschreibung wenn
die dazu eine meinung hat zu diesem
thema klicken auf den link in der
beschreibung dürfte der erste sein und
stimmt da ab da habe ich halt gefragt
was haltet ihr davon
das so oft kommt das ist cool für euch
und leidet wegen mir und da habe ich
unser erstes abgeschlossen und das ich
mitbekomme moment mal gut dann direkt
mal crack pro ist wert 110 beginn vom
projektchor unter auf 100 das ist mein
normales auto wie deswegen wird das
würde wahrscheinlich das leicht ist am
heutigen tage
aber ich sag euch leute am ende wird's
richtig schwierig am ende wird es
richtig schwierig wenn man im etui ganz
runter geht dann irgendwann in die
bereiche kommt die selbst ein computer
und ein sturm waffe noch nie gesehen
haben es geht nämlich runter bis 11.30
und 30 einfach unspielbar sebari wird
selbst sehen also wir gehen runter auf
90 weitere zehn noch machen noch machbar
würde ich sagen ist doch relativ nah
dran am sowie 100 mit dem ich
normalerweise spiele aber es geht auf
jeden fall bergab leute man kann einfach
gar nicht mehr einschätzen wie groß die
abstände sind so wirklich wie gesagt am
90 euro wie geht das noch bei einem 30 m
v
so seltsam aus den 50-er was ich schon
mal drin hatte das quasi unspielbar
also man muss man muss raten wo die
blöcke aufhören muss wirklich einfach
raten
man hat das nun im gefühl letzten
checkpoint weitere zehn runter auf 80
euro natürlich lassen wir übrigens auch
im deathmatch dann das drin was wir am
ende haben
das heißt wir kämpfen wenn er mit mit 40
uhr also so ok jemand das sehr schön
etwa 80 80 ist schon auch schon sehr
grenzwertig also die ganzen projekt
profis genossen unter euch werden sich
schon vor schmerzen krümmt mir leid
leute aber das ist die heutige challenge
80er frieren jetzt gespielt so regen
runter auf enorme so das ist jetzt 100
congo after 100% sturm offen
zumindest hat er früher mit diesem level
gespielt ist auch kein held oder so aber
da werde ich ein youtuber denke der mit
erwin norwig spielt eigentlich für luca
eigentlich gemacht auch im pvp deswegen
muss sturm den kopf hinhalten so und wir
haben schon das nächste modul geschafft
das heißt wir gehen noch mal runter und
jetzt wird's langsam aber sicher richtig
v60 haben wir jetzt schon zehn
unternommen
ich weiß ganz solches überhaupt spiel
oder wiederverwertet die aufnahme
einfach umbringen hier deutschland
schnappt läutet leute
nein das ist dieses jahr ja ich sehe den
blöcken genehmigt hat steht möchte dass
leute ich sehe mir bleibt nicht mehr so
ich kann locker die noch einen halben
meter auf dem block laufen
meter für meter als maßeinheit in
minecraft anzuwenden
jetzt hänge ich dran sehr schön ja okay
und wir haben ein check bauleute und
jetzt betet für mich und betet für
meinen skill falls es ihn gibt
genauso wie 50 runter
das ist lächerlich leute potter herr
okay aber so weit geht es doch soweit
geht habe ich das verwechselt das modul
nicht ab es ist sogar relativ machbar
vor dem gp im deathmatch wird etwa wie
50 wir sind trotz der mvc einfach auf
platz eins was mich auch ein bisschen an
den fähigkeiten der anderen leute in der
runde ja gerade zweifeln lässt
ich kannte nur einschätzen
wie ich lauf muss okay das hat aber
gereicht wird leute kommen
man sieht einfach als mit dem blog nicht
das tut weh oh okay avenches und in
zweiten verdammten diamanten und wir
haben tatsächlich geschafft
wir sind auf dem wir sind auf dem ja ja
können wir können wir ich war so weit
ich war so weit dafür da vorne und da
bleibt viel kopf hin
es ist kein leben aber okay gut 20
sekunden
ganz ehrlich hat irgend einer von euch
erwartet dass ich die runde finnische
wir haben zwar die us-kräfte finden dann
haben wir chancen und jetzt leute enjoy
pvp 50 wie gesagt leute die empfindlich
auf vw entscheidung reagieren sollten
spätestens jetzt abschalten weil das ist
einfach nur lächerlich
der typ fühlt man ganz bild aus mann ich
bin so nah an ihm dran als wirklich im
garten schmutz die bot gegeben es ist
die beste was ihr lass mich in dein
eines rainer sauer man natürlich in die
kommen sehen und liebesbrand aber damit
getötet
alles klar das erste von drei leben ist
weg und vielleicht sagen jetzt bisschen
defensiv spielen vielleicht aber auch
nicht
man sieht dass ich lasse die treppe hoch
und ich sehe es als man sich drei
treppenstufen sonst nichts
mann oh mann da und ist ein eckpfeiler
und hatten diesmal ich ja wohl alter und
unser nächster kill wir haben jetzt
nimmer neutrale kde wir um zwei leute
gibt ja positive im zwei leute getötet
und sind bisher noch einmal gestorben
alter
ganz ehrlich pvp gott 2016 dankeschön
abonniert in den kommentaren
falls ihr das nicht wissen oder fragt
was das hier gerade soll ich's nickel
gerade nicht ja ich sprinte und jetzt
sprintet und springe ich das ist
schnellstmöglich hat sich fortzubewegen
hier zu fuß und mit falschen als ob der
will mich überhaupt nein nein nein nein
einfach nein heute auch gewässer aber
dass nur fast hab ich nur ein holzschild
brune
das habe ich dann gesehen dass da nur
ein holzschild bei dir ist und wir haben
die op kombos haben
als ich gerade eben rüber zu ihm aufs
hausdach gesprungen bin dachte ich mir
so oh gott das ist genau der moment in
dem du stirbst v marcel getroffen aber
wir haben es tatsächlich geschafft wir
haben ihn getötet
übrigens ja die ganz professionell und
langjährigen zuschauer und zuhörer
merken auch dass meine stimme so ein
bisschen belegt ist
ich selbst fühle mich fit aber wir haben
halt gestern in köln kann aber gefallen
was entsprechender teil ab war wie man
im fachjargon sagt es ist mit den leuten
los und auch sonst kämpft irgendwie
niemand in dieser runde ist euch das
aufgefallen niemand alle spielen wie
verstecken das nicht heidel sieht man ja
oder nein
ja leute natürlich versteckt euch doch
alle auf einen dachboden leute als ich
meine es ernst ich glaube ich habe
keinen mist wie so verstecken sich allem
alle ausnahmslos alle kämpfe pro jahr
oder ich riechen cleanup ich rieche ihn
habt ihr recht gut frischer knuspriger
cleanup roja wolle die sehr schön als
kleine rache dafür mlg von dach als wir
sind dreimal in diesem haus und ich
rechne noch knusprigen klima was gerade
eben zucker bleibt das so ein
großprojekt ihn ab jawohl rostig rostig
profitabel
nadal kann ist x16 1x bin ich bin ich
jedoch gut mit
wir können uns auf jeden fall schon mal
nervös machen junge haben wir viele
flintstones fit flitzt uns und unser
letzter gegner ist wieder der meister
des versteckens herrscher dj wer kennt
ihn nicht und davon ist da ich sie sah
nahm schnell schnell an ihn ran bevor
sich irgendwas ist da unten
ja ich hole ja ja ja ja
lauf lauf lauf profitierte mich nein sie
bitte dass ich überleben so ok ich kann
mir immer tot stellen
aber das war eine schlechte idee jetzt
fängst du noch ein und xml jäger nein
nein nein nicht m lg
stimmt ab wie habe ich mich entschieden
habe ich ihn getötet oder habe ich ein
leben lassen habe ich mit ihm meldet
oder habe ich nun gelegt schreibt jetzt
die kommentare etwa fünf sekunden
abzustimmen
er hat mrd ich habe zwar angst aber
jetzt stirbt harry braun karierten doch
kann nicht der weg und ihr direkter so
viel verraten so viel leben
java ist er in alter meister
okay leute das was von heutigen folge
wenn ihr so lange durchgehalten hat muss
man eigentlich sagen kriegt ihr dafür
auf jeden fall einen plastikflaschen
deckel
ich hab einfach eure adresse in die
kommentare adressen die kommentare was
kann leichter und weitere change
vorschläge in die kommentare wir sehen
uns bei der nächsten folge bis dann
macht's gut